great episode hey babe coming up we get
uh into our lives on this one we talk
about our first long-term girlfriends in
high school and how those relationships
panned out yeah you had a crazy one
where you actually went to
with your girlfriend to pick up her
father yes the day he was released the
day it was released you'll hear about
that you hear about sal's restaurant
ideas uh it's bread it's budget that's
all you need to know
um we we bust out access to jamaican we
have a ball of fun on this episode um
and yeah we talk about all types of
things this is one of the only recent
episodes we don't talk about time travel
yeah really no but this was a these flew
by today these are good this can be a
fun one you guys don't like this episode
you got the merch you know all about it
it's up on our websites check it out and
then uh
and if you don't like this episode you
take it up with bloom counter pick it up
with blue cafe you'll get it you'll get
it when you watch it get it when you
watch this episode you'll understand
what that means especially where she's
streaming on netflix
july we're in providence august end of
august we're at the bray improv in
california and september 30th chicago
theater chrisdcomedy.com tomorrow night
i'm in hampton beach casino in hampton
new hampshire uh and then the next day
i'm at foxwoods and the big one here
july i'm at the virgin hotel new virgin
hotel the theater there you ever go
there yet no that's supposed to be
really cool beautiful i think it's that
they're getting into the comedy game
over there at the virgin the virgin yeah
july 15th come by uh fly in vegas july
and vegas it should be real nice nice uh
how about this one next day i'm in
phoenix
july 16th at the celebrity theater july
17th in boulder colorado and then the
week after that portland seattle and
vancouver all in july come on out
savilecanoncomedy.com
and do us a favor please if you can
subscribe to our channel on youtube the
no press channel follow us on spotify
rate us on itunes it's a big help uh if
you want to do something to help the
podcast because you like it we're not
you know just do that for us we
appreciate it and enjoy the
episode don't run away from your
feelings
[Music]
[Applause]
hey babe
what's up babe what's up baby how you
doing i'm doing good and i'm having fun
i'm in a good mood i'm energetic i i i
you know just i'm in a positive mood and
that doesn't happen a lot i just had
that was cooked
uh in your home yeah eggs
uh spinach maybe
uh was it yeah okay tomatoes
green onions
parmesan cheese but it was a parmesan
cheese wrap that was folded oh into the
eggs and then on top of that parmesan
cheese wrap a wrap wrap a rags wrap was
folded on top of that and i've had
in my life
i would say if i did guess
5 000 egg sandwiches let's add 5 000 egg
sandwiches in my life yeah that sounds
right that one that i had was in the top
three
it's hopped three out of five thousand
out of five thousand i'm willing that
good i'm willing to tell you that one
wow also the bacon egg and cheese i had
at island coffee shop on staten island
shout out island coffee shop that was
pretty good too but
that was in the top three you see those
new wraps that are made with like
they're like wraps but they're like a
thin layer of like cheese that's because
it's like a keto wrap or something or
something like that i suppose i mean
isn't there
who do you think
i mean genuinely
do you think
like what do people hate more than bread
in 2020
no i know they love it but i'm saying
it's the campaign against bread
if you're if you're publishing a number
in store right now today you're finding
a loser no but everybody's looking for
bread alternatives did you know that i
wanted to open a bread store i swear
sweaty really yeah it's cool it was
gonna be called bread and butter and i
just wanted to serve bread and butter
all different types of breads all
different types of butters mix and match
gourmet fresh made maybe have some beers
and you're gonna count and talk you out
of it and maybe some tap maybe some like
olives and stuff like that
basically it's a place to go and just
have the bread and butter and have a and
have a drink
um
i don't hate the idea i i i think i
spoke to one of my friends who was a
restaurant tour about it
and he was like south i don't know why i
netted it out i think i just didn't want
to dedicate my life
to bread and butter
yeah i think i just because it's one of
those things where it's like listen you
can get bread and butter here at my
store or also in prison it's the same
yeah this is this it's it's like you
know you know what i mean though right
you go in and this gourmet list of
breads and a gourmet list of there's
pairings and there's deals you can get a
flight of breads or something
right you get some wines you get some
some beers in there and maybe maybe
maybe some like olives cheese and fruit
like a little like a you know but but
mostly it's just the bread and the
butter
i i think it's the best food ever known
to man i think what about this what
about if we combine ideas
what if
the new menu item
at joey rose's sandwich shop is just
bread and butter blows your mind wait
there's nothing else on this it's just
it's a toasted hoagie with butter
yeah well
we call that a buttered roll maybe
what do you think he has the stones to
do that to put a fresh baked loaf on
there with just hot butter
butter and it melts and then that's what
you get i think what joe de rosa lacks
in shoulders he makes up
your courage yeah i think that's where
because joe's courage is not in his
shoulders
no it's not no no it's not in his
shoulders nothing's actually in his
shoulder
even though he lifts his arms
um so so but i think bread and butter
it's an you know what i would say too
you know what i think is happening now
starting to happen
is we've been given so many options in
life for so long when we lived in a
world where there wasn't that many
options like when mcdonald's first
started you could get a cheeseburger
hamburger that's it go [ __ ] yourself
right and then now there's been millions
too much so now i think places that
combat that go with less options are
doing better than with more options like
even now i notice like on flights it's
less options uh there's a pizzeria that
opened up not too long ago les you can
get regular or pepperoni yeah that's it
that's all they do is one thing i kind
of think that's going back so it might
now it might not have been i think i
think time is on your side and i think
that yeah
yes it is i think now is the time
to open up the bread and butter store
because people i would like to go in
there if you told me here's what you can
get in my store no thoughts you come in
you get bread you get butter you get
coffee that's what you can get yeah i
would know it's like it's like having a
trainer at the gym you don't have to
think going into breadboard coffee same
thing as having a coffee that's my
trainer i i see so i was picturing as
more of a place that you can come to
socialize and have a bread of butter
have a conversation grab a pint or
something like that but you're right i
don't want to be like a breakfast spot
or anything but you're right just coffee
bread and butter but it's not a bakery
that's the thing it's like you can buy
lows today when you're getting your
bread you can buy those to go but we're
fresh baking that [ __ ] like subway like
we're we have like a
you know we we fresh bake every day
though you know what's crazy like a
baker i guess you can go to a bake or a
good bakery and do this one time i was
on a subway i was at a subway
and and you know they're making their
sandwich and the guy in front of me like
you know like you know says you know the
guy's like do you know do you want mayo
yeah relish whatever yeah and then the
guy go and then the the the
subway worker says oh you know would you
like chips with that he goes yeah i like
my chips on the sandwich and then i
no i've never heard of that no i put
them on myself maybe no they did it no
the worker
this is a i wish i had video evidence of
this i i only thought of it with the
bread and butter
the worker then took a bag of cool ranch
doritos and just put the plastic bag on
the guy's sandwich and started to wrap
it up no i i was like did i see that he
just put
wrapped it up and then i watched the man
go sit down unwrap a sandwich and take
the bag of plastic bag of chips out of
the sandwich and then open up the bag of
chips and put them on the sandwich
themselves that's the crack squad of
savvy personnel they're hiring over
there at subway yeah when you go into a
subway the problem is with subway first
of all i love to eat fresh the problem
is with the subway though is i can never
get the smell of subway off my clothes
like going into a cigar lounge i like
cigars i don't like what they do to my
clothes
yeah i used to work at a deli and i used
to work in this and that's it you you
come home i swear to god you just smell
like baloney where was the day
was another corner of highland and yeah
babe
tompkins dude convenient food mart still
there 24 7. okay well whoever the owner
is because that's where bloom cafe is
bloom cafe is right there bloom cafe i
talked about the last episode vegan
great cafe
on bay street bay street
that deli whoever owns that i part there
was the staten island it was a five
borough bike tour so they had parts of
staten island closed
and the street that i needed to get to
to go to bloom cafe was closed so i
couldn't park my car i had to park my
car
in that they're not cool with that
deli's parking you know why and then
quickly run across sheet when i came out
the guy was like i'm calling the tow
trump tow truck company your car's about
to get towed you can't move i said
where's the tow truck he said he's a few
minutes away i said see you later he
goes i have your license plate i was
like good
good give it to the tow truck
i'm leaving with my food like right i
wanted to drive my car through that deli
yeah so that's happened people have
driven their car through it number one
and like i when we had it on security
cam two places i've worked in my life a
car came through the front and just went
smashed through a bar i worked at and uh
and uh the uh that convenient feature
neither time you were there neither time
i was there neither time nobody died
nobody died and i have and i saw both of
them on the security tapes wow but what
happens is right behind that convenient
food mart is a post office
and for 30 years people have been
parking there and going in the post
office
so they like they've had they have
they've had enough with it but the guy
that works there now i don't even know
like i i i knew the first owner yeah
this guy came out and started screaming
at me and i was just like why like what
kind of threat is that even if you were
a police officer and you were like don't
move the tow truck freeze i would be
like you're on foot dude yeah you're on
then go through the trouble google my
address just google my ad google my
how were you reacting to him when he
said that i literally just like were you
also just like [ __ ]
i had an off coffee in my hand and then
i had a vegan egg and cheese quesadilla
and one of those gluten-free devil dogs
in the other hand and i was just like
are you serious right now and he was
like yeah you need to wait here you
legally need to wait here i called the
tow truck i was like sorry buddy he was
like well i'm writing down your license
plate i was like good i was like my
license plate it's it's it's uh it's
attached to my mother's address so
you'll never find me
so you can go arrest my mother yeah what
are they what are they gonna he's gonna
make that call oh what happens to you
there you should know what you should
have did you should have said this take
it up with bloom cafe
yes i would have said that get up and
start a war start oh my god yeah um i'm
gonna start telling people to do that
when i'm angry to take it up with
somebody else just say take it up at
bloom cafe
people go out are gonna go outside bloom
cafe and go take it up with bloom count
sir uh i didn't call group one yet i've
only called people with children i take
it up with bloom cafe i'm getting on the
plane go into bloom cafe on bay street
in staten island buy uh gluten free
dairy free devil dog or whatever food
item you want
send a video tag hey bay pod and scream
take it up with bloom cafe
i'm tagging we'll retweet the best ones
but you have to buy their food oh god
for no reason we should that just should
be their new slogan we should call them
on the phone right now be like hi we're
two comedians we're from the
neighborhood and we think your slogan
should be taken up with bloom cafe what
do you guys think of that
speak if i owned a place called bloom
cafe this one i'd have the workers in a
shirt like this doesn't this shirt say
bloom cafe it does it's not sure
i love your color story today thank you
what a nice palette company the
roosevelts rsv ltf shout out to them
before they sent i mentioned i'm
shouting them on joe rogan shout out joe
rogan if you if you're listening we know
that you are yeah
we i just bought one of their shirts
within the first 30 seconds of me doing
the joe roger show joe rogan goes that's
the worst shirt i've ever seen
i said it's it's the roosevelt i love it
and then i shout out the roosevelts and
even though joe rogan said he didn't
like the shirt they sent me a package of
their shirts because it's good fit and i
think they have good color summer
schemes yeah i think you look it's a
vibrancy coming off of you that you
didn't have prior to wearing that shirt
appreciate it
now sal let me ask you this
one because
you know i know we've talked about i i
think a few episodes ago we talked about
psychedelics i've been telling you i've
been on doing edibles and things like
that
do you think there's a point in your
life ever do you think there's a point
where you just just to try just to say
you did it cross off the course of this
would you do lsd angel dust never in my
life no chance
we were just talking about this a couple
nights ago someone's mentioned the word
molly and i said ah because we looked up
how prince and michael jackson died
because we thought it was the same way
is it in fentanyl
prince was took a vicodin that was laced
with too much fat that was laced with
fentanyl prince the i i mean the uh uh
an icon on this earth
probably worth a billion dollars he died
from bad bad drugs that he bought yeah i
mean that's that's like that's what
happens
it couldn't have been official vikes
right because official vicodin from a
company isn't gonna be laced with
fentanyl so he bought so why didn't
anyone hunt him down the way they hunted
down mac miller's folks and stuff
maybe they maybe they did some street
justice i don't know i didn't hear
nothing of it
but michael jackson died because his
doctor prescribed him like a
cocktail of [ __ ] and then i heard that
michael jackson if his guy would have
came in and just moved his head he would
have lived
really i think the way he was positioned
made him this is what i read so do you
think he wanted to kill michael jackson
no no no but i think it said it's like
it's really this really really weird
thing that if the doctor would have come
in and repositioned him from the way he
was laying or something he would have
lived something crazy
interesting
do you think
if they were still segregating
cemeteries would michael jackson be
buried as a white woman or a black man
it's i mean i don't know what he was i
don't know where he was headed if this
was a period of time do you think he's
in heaven as a what do you think he what
race is he in heaven as right now i
think he's the race he was born with why
did they remove michael jackson's brain
they removed his brain
scientists need to remove the pop star's
brain to finish his autopsy and because
it takes about two weeks for a brain to
harden before it can be examined if he's
laid to rest before then his body will
have to be buried without his brain do
you remember that what happens to anyone
with an autopsy i guess so yeah oh my
god do you remember exactly where you
were when michael jackson died
like i do remember where i was
when i was watching jfk and found out
that jfk died
when i was watching the movie jfk and i
found out jfk died i remember where i
was you didn't know he died until you
saw the movie yeah uh you what you
didn't die what year michael jackson
died go 2009
that's correct
yeah because i was i was had uh just
beginning to do like thinking about the
idea of doing comedy open mics and i
remember i was on my way i was on i
think it was the bad slava website i
hadn't ever got on stage yet but i was
on my way to try to do my first open mic
and i was obviously very nervous and i
was like
new york and i remember sitting in
traffic and it blasts all over the radio
michael jackson dead and i said i can't
take this right now i can't do the open
mic and then i didn't try it again for
about six months
no i was looking for any excuse in the
universe to not have to do this open mic
because i was terrified so when michael
jackson died i said you did that for me
jesus killed michael jackson so i would
have to do the open mic at stand-up new
york yeah and i've turned around and
went home
new york was like hey you were on a
schedule you didn't show up what do you
tell him michael jackson died no take it
up with bloom cafe making up a blue cafe
uh michael jackson died allegedly
allegedly
i pointed to a picture of him from
thriller
i don't remember where i was when
michael jackson died to tell you the
truth but do you consider yourself a
worse person for that
i remember i was when princess die died
i remember i was too you know i don't
know why i just because i distinctly
remember waking up turned on television
and it was like this big thing
i remember i remember when princess
diana died i was in my stepmother's
bedroom taking a nap
for some reason i don't know why
well my i guess my dad and stepmother's
budget i was laying on my stepmother's
side of the bed
i remember for some reason she had a
nightgown and i was using her nightgown
as a zillow i think i say as a tissue as
a tissue
it was weird i remember i don't know why
i remember that where were you when
princess died i was at my first my first
girlfriend's family's house
and uh it was in the morning and i just
we turned on the television and it was
like the whole scene you know the
helicopters and [ __ ] like that and i was
like whoa and you went you were at her
family's house her house yeah yeah yeah
yeah what were you guys doing
well i just woken up i had slept over oh
you saw you were allowed to sleep over
your girlfriend's house when you were a
teenager i know it sounds weird but like
my parents allowed it and her parents
allowed it in the same bed you had to
sleep on the floor
in the same bed
what
yeah what kind of parents did you guys
have i think that we were just two
respectful kids and like you didn't do
any hanky-panky parents trusted us and
you didn't do anything i think it was
everything everything was on the up and
up you know like how old were you and
when princess died
16. i guess what was i 16 15
that's crazy that parents would let you
do that because i know i know it sounds
weird because i would never in a million
years do that but we dated for like six
years
maybe it was a little later maybe it was
like we were 18. no listen you're the
type of boyfriend you know i have two
daughters i want my daughters to come
home with a guy like you oh i want my
daughter to come home with a guy like
you because i say i'll say
i can this guy is a nice guy's
respectful guy he's put together he's
successful he's trustworthy and he's
most likely and he's mostly
yeah
i would say
i would say
and he's most likely gay
so i would say this guy
this guy makes me feel safe and good at
night
so
so
so i would say uh hold hold i was 20. oh
okay
so now now it actually goes now it's
actually like what the hell were you
guys sleeping because now it's like a
20. well i guess at 20 you're still
going to be living at home with you know
i i was living at home with my wife yeah
i was too yeah you're right you're right
this makes sense i was three months
before 21. but were you sleeping at a 20
year old almost on the verge of being 21
year old were you sleeping
was it a basement apartment that she had
were you sleeping
upstairs like their parent's bedroom was
right next door yeah she would wake up
and have to use no no parents
bedroom was downstairs it was just a
small two family ass and her two
brothers bedrooms were upstairs
wow she was sleeping next to her
brothers
well in another room but still why
yeah but you understand we start dating
this person 15. did you have the sleep
apnea mask yet not yet okay
didn't get that till my mids
20s or 30s you did it six years i think
my late no i got that you know when i
got that [ __ ] no probably my late 20s
you did six years 15 to 21
yeah wow that's kind of crazy were you
thinking about proposing to her yeah wow
i never told you this story no
i i had a whole proposal uh
arranged
guys
for most of us learning a second
language in high school or college
wasn't exactly the high point of our
academic years no yeah i i you don't
really learn it you don't take it with
you but now and i it's one of my biggest
forgets you know my grandparents were
spanish speaking i took spanish in high
school i got slightly conversational i
forgot it all and i always regret it you
need to be if you need to be one thing
in this world you need to be bilingual
if you need to be one thing if you're
gonna be bi be bisexual be bilingual
boom now thanks to babel the language
learning app that sold more than 10
million subscriptions there's an
addictively fun and easy way to learn a
new language whether you'll be traveling
abroad connecting in a deeper way with
family or just you know you want to
brush it up in your free time babel
teaches bite-sized language lessons that
you'll actually use in the real world uh
and it is really fun it's 15-minute
lessons they make it really fun to learn
on the app it's a way they do it in the
way that you actually retain it um
there's over 14 languages on there you
know when i and cause all these other
language apps they use artificial
intelligence not babble what babble does
is they have language experts they took
over 100 language experts and they
created this app so you get in the
dialect right you get you're really
sounding like you're in real people are
teaching you it it's not a machine
it's not a sheen man
no there's so many ways to learn with
babble uh in addition to the lessons
there's podcast games videos stories and
even live classes scroll pimpy
start your new language uh learning
journey today with babel uh right now
you're doing on a plane on the bus into
the world the plane is the best i love
doing babylon yeah right now save up to
60 percent off your uh subscription when
you go to babel.com hey babe that's
babel it's b-a-b-b-e-l
dot com slash hey babe for up to 6-0 60
off your subscription babel language for
life
this podcast is sponsored by
betterhelp.com if you're watching right
now and you have some sort of thing
plaguing you on your mind bothering you
you're run down you are fatigued you
have lack of motivation maybe you're
doing depressed and you want to speak to
somebody but you don't go to therapy you
don't you're intimidated by it better
help is awesome because they they
connect you in 48 hours to an online
professional therapist and uh because
it's online they they can you can reach
place but you know therapists that deal
in special things that aren't even in
your area it's accessible it makes every
therapist accessible right it does it
really does i literally i was listening
to you talk and i was like
in my head i'm like you know
i forgot to
do my session today with better help and
i felt like a little i was wondering why
i feel so disjointed today i'm like oh
because i didn't talk to my my therapist
on better i better help i've missed the
appointment so now i'm just going to go
ahead i'm going to make an appointment
for later today they have plenty of
people that can help you and it's just
that easy it's all online it's you can
even do a phone call you don't have to
go to an office that's what's great it's
if i miss my therapist appointment and i
actually physically have to be in the
room with them then it's like i gotta
wait for two weeks blah blah blah now
with better help no better help is
customized online therapy that offers
video phone and even live chat sessions
with your therapist so you don't have to
see anyone on camera if you don't want
to it's much more affordable than in
person therapy and you can be matched
with therapists another 48 hours our
listeners get 10 off their first month
at betterhelp.com hey babe you know we
love them that's b e t t e r h e l p dot
com slash hey babe try it out
um i didn't tell you i never told you i
think i told you this guys the letter
yeah okay i did tell you i didn't
understand yeah we're sleeping with her
parents and her brothers
no i wasn't sleeping with her parents
and her brother my brother's nice to you
or they're like no no very nice near my
sister no no her older brother was one
year older than me younger brother was a
few years younger than me i mean we
families were close to everything we
dated for six you know it wasn't like
that a thing
did i ever tell you my first girlfriend
story ever yeah like girls oh virginity
two minutes
no so
you know we were you know hooking up
whatever like i didn't ask any questions
i met her mom i just assumed like her
mom and dad were not together never
asked i don't know why i was whatever 17
not asking any questions about a father
yeah so then she says to me once because
i had a car she says to me one day she
didn't have a car she goes can you drive
with me to pick up my dad i want to meet
want you to meet him and i was like yeah
sure we were dating for a couple months
or it was like great and so we're
driving there and i was like thought i
was like where are we going airport like
his house she goes no we're just going
to pick him up so we thousand percent
true story we picked him up from prison
we go i'm joking no no no i'm joking i'm
joking
i'm joking
um so
we go to
the metropolitan brooklyn detention
center on atlantic avenue
this is
allegedly
this is two thousand
maybe the year two or two thousand one
we go and she goes just wait right here
i'm going to be like an hour i have to
sign him out
and i said wait a second
i said hold on hold on hold on i said
what do you mean sign him out she goes
he's he's in prison he's he's out now
and i'm going to sign him out that is
and we're going to take him to his
halfway house but you can meet him i've
told him all about you are you going to
take them all the way there though and i
said
i like that joke that's doing all day
i'm not so fold full are you gonna take
the full trip to the halfway house i
like it play with words i'm playing with
words classic
um
so
i go
what
so she goes yeah he's a nice guy and
then i said to him and i swear to god i
said what was he in prison for and she
said murder
so he had been in prison for like 12
years
the lit
listen
first girl great girl um how old were
you half half jamaican half italian
i was 17 or 18. chef jamaican half
italian very beautiful what a mix
beautiful girl how old are you 17 18.
she was around your age same age so she
her dad went into prison when she was a
tyke tyke
so so
i'm waiting there for 45 minutes
gets in the car gets in the back seat
okay she gets in the front seat gets in
the back seat
and then i forgot i mean did you watch
them embrace or something like no
they're walking i mean the mother didn't
go
no no they're divorced okay mama
divorced
comes in he sits in the back seat i a
toy i had a toyota corolla he gets in
the back seat i turn around i said hi
mister i want to give her away her last
name i said hi mr mr h and he goes
potato head say it and he goes he goes
sorry okay swear to god he goes
my doctor didn't tell me he was white
and i said
i said um i i am i said i'm i'm uh i'm
white she goes my daughter didn't tell
me she was [ __ ] with no white boy
no
no
first of all i've never heard you do it
you're making an accent did i nail it
pretty good pretty good
you sound like jamaican mixed with
something else i can't place yet but
i'll try i'm a jamaican chinese
because you didn't tell me you was white
[Laughter]
yeah yeah at any moment just say do the
jamaican i'll say yeah yeah yeah yeah
she goes yeah so
so i go i go yeah yeah i'm white and she
goes
i gotta go he goes my doctor's not
allowed to date no white boy
and then i was like would you like a
ride
to your halfway house you know i can
i'll take your halfway house he goes he
goes me doctor and me going to take the
bus
and then you're turning irish but sorry
and then well that's the thing with me
you can't have me go on two that's it
it's jamaican irish jamaican yeah so
then i say to my girlfriend at the time
i said what am i supposed to do here and
she goes well i'm gonna go with my dad
and i was like
okay i was like you know you should have
told the father when he said that she
didn't he didn't know she was dating the
white why
take it up with bloom cafe
[Laughter]
so wait so you're now are you are you
scared of the man or is he just he looks
like a regular fellow or does he look
like oh this is a guy who's been mixing
it up in there he looked like to be
honest with you he looked like a slight
fellow
um like slender okay where i kind of was
like at that point like i'll beat the
[ __ ] out of this guy
but
so
i said so she like left with him and
they got on the bus but his wife was
white
this is doesn't make any sense okay so
then i remember
she at that point had a beeper with no
cell phone so i beat her like whatever
it was two hours later and she called me
back from his house and she was like
yeah my dad said we can't really be
together
anymore and i was like okay like you
know like but like i thought like we
were in love and she was like yeah she
was like but you know my dad said uh my
dad said we just we we can't be together
anymore and i was like shh i was like
yeah but i i love my like i like i'm
like in love with you right and like i
lost my virginity to you or anything
like that and she was just like look he
said i'm not allowed to date uh a white
person a white boy did she did she tell
you to take her
huh did she tell you to take it
tell me to take it up with a bloom
catcher if she would have told you that
i would have been but then what i did
was then i said i'm gonna fix this and
then i showed up the next day to her and
her father's house with a do-rag
a joke that's a joke okay no but i did
fight i did fight fight fight for my
right to party with her and then i
eventually was able to turn the father
around and begin to somewhat like turn
the data
how i got to get him to like me was
because i was playing basketball in my
high school my college so i was playing
in a men's league and he liked
basketball
so i was a you know decent basketball
player and had a good jump shot and i
remember like he liked that he was like
you can play
you got the jump shot
yeah
if i remember he rekindled and he was
cool
she broke up with me to date her
ex-boyfriend really yeah i got dumped
her ex-boyfriend who was who was who was
uh i think like he literally
as jamaican as he looked like he sounded
like he was actively in the movie cool
runnings right
full jamaican couldn't really he was
speaking english but like he was in the
whalers yes yes he was in cool runnings
and um and uh yeah her ex was john candy
and um
[Laughter]
and so and so i remember but i remember
that moment i i've never told you that i
remember that moment him being like
know white bite yeah that's great yeah
yeah if i close my eyes that's what it
is i feel like you're a bobsled medalist
qualifier or whatever imagine being on
the jamaican pops like didn't you say
you met them pimp the guys from the
jamaican bobsled team yeah they were
like used as like a decoration at a
hamptons party
like they flew them out just to stand
there with the medals in a certain like
area of the party and that's it though
yeah
got flown home they've got an appearance
made an appearance made an appearance
appearance isn't the easiest way to make
money in appearance believe that [ __ ]
but it feels pony i'll appear i'll
appear there yeah i'll appear have you
done it
i've done appearances it has to feel so
awful it felt like uh have i done
appearances have i done appearances i
feel like i've done appearances speaking
of speaking of appearances you know
who's reappeared fart jar girl remember
the girl used to fart in the jars yeah
and then she went to the hospital
because she was trying to force out too
much too many farts now there's a girl
uh the same girl selling her boob sweat
for five five thousand dollars a day
she's making in boob sweat
is she lying
no i think that you the thing is what
you would think these women are lying
but the thing is is that it's all
provable like they can prove it all she
also launched competition only fans
she's deep in this world she watched
what uh com a competitive app with only
fans oh she launched a competitive app
she did yeah with only fans because
she's deep in this well dude i have a
friend i obviously won't give his name
but i have a friend who worked he was
like a maintenance worker in the
building she lived in he said you know
he had to go do maintenance in her
apartment once like i think he's an air
conditioner guy it broke he said her
apartment is
insanely beautiful it was only her that
lived there and all that was fart money
all that was fart money you're kidding
me i swear to god you should build a
fortress on farts the fortress of farts
yeah so now so i don't know what he said
and she moved out to get a bigger place
after she had already
you know like farted herself into the
hospital so now this boob sweat money
yeah and you know what else she's like
what else could come out of my body
which i don't know if i'm selling this
but again i'm not giving away any name
or
like i'm just his job it could be
anywhere he said when they were cleaning
our apartment she had a bag of dildos
like on the floor that she just left for
them to find are you serious garbage bag
full of dildos wow yeah that he said
smell like farts yeah yeah they gotta
let me ask you a question how much does
a tit how much is it it's sweat
that you're you can put it into a jar
and sell enough of the tit sweat to make
5 000 a day hear me out
you run out of trouble for a half hour
how much tits what are you getting i
don't think my tits even really sweat
that much i know also how is she
how is she getting this tit sweat
in its into a jar
there can't be all it can't be that is
awesome she's disgusting she's offered
to come on guys we can we can ask her
what would you rather do
put on my booger shorts or drink her
tits sweat oh my god it's going to be
put on your book of shorts put them on
you said right just put them on
i can't drink
i can't drink tits what did you ever see
the jackass where they get on the bikes
the stationary bikes and they got tubes
attached to their bodies their asses and
then they just do and then someone
is at the other edge drink of the sweat
that comes off
jackass is disgusting
that one will make me throw up could you
imagine they did a show switch once and
you had to do an episode of jackass and
stevo did the jokers not at all i
wouldn't be able to do it you wouldn't
be able to get their way no way i mean
even eric andre didn't survive the movie
like yeah he got beat up on that set
yeah he was scared i'm still waiting to
watch it yeah yeah yeah it's a classic
the new ones have you done stevo's i'm
supposed to do stevo's podcast no i've
only met stevo once he was the nicest
guy but
i don't really know him besides that one
interaction which i doubt he remembers
all right dude true bill
this little you could see commercials
it i think it's my favorite
my favorite app i've ever had in my life
because you know how many times i've
just been on auto uh every month it's
been on auto pay for something i haven't
used in months sometimes i haven't used
in years true bill what it does is you
plug in your information it removes you
from all this stuff it saves you so much
money true bill got your back they got
your back it's a new app that helps you
identify and stop paying for
subscriptions you don't need one or
simply forgot about i was in that boat
along with millions of other people they
scam you they they know you know
and they make it hard to find out how to
cancel again which i can't stand and i
downloaded this when they started doing
it and i i actually was able to cancel a
few things that cancel peacock blossom i
canceled peacock and i also canceled an
apple game subscription that i had for
eight months and i wasn't playing it my
gym told me i needed a letter from my
doctor to cancel i signed up on my true
bill cancelled into here's your letter
yeah i said take it up with blue take it
up with boom cafe and your true bit and
the true bill they have a concierge and
they're there for you you talk to them
and they whenever you need them to
cancel i want the descriptions you may
have forgotten about they do it for it's
like you having a personal system
imagine get on the phone and be like
cancel all my stuff yeah hold my calls
cancel my stuff thank you yeah truebill
they have over 2 million users and
they've helped save them over 100
million dollars matthew b says in a
matter of seconds i saved 660 dollars
for the year on my direct tv bill save
the 120 for the year on my serious exam
bill saved 840 a year on car insurance
so wow maddie b is up 16 in a few
minutes matthew b is doing good don't
fall for subscription scams start
canceling today at truebuild.com
hey babe go right now truebill.com hey
babe it could save you thousands a year
get cancelled truebuild.com hey babe
ship station baby
listen i like e-commerce we gotta sell
merch we gotta sell things a lot of you
guys have online companies out there
it's all about selling online today baby
and ship station makes it perfect you
got to ship things out on time
properly it's what customers love
shipstation is trusted by over 100 000
sellers it automates time intensive
shipping processes so you can get back
to focusing on bigger things like
developing new products honing your
marketing strategy or interacting with
customers
all those manual shipping tasks that eat
up your time ship station is awesome at
those okay so when you left why don't
you let ship station handle all your
shipping handle all your handling and
you can get back to what you're good at
which is growing your business and it
works with every storefront amazon ebay
sd whatever you want to do they got it
98 of companies that use ship station
for a year keep using it for as long as
they're in business
right now using the promo code hey babe
go to shipstation.com
and you will get a free 60-day trial
that's
shipstation.com promo code hey babe
click on the microphone at the top of
the page and type in hey babe and you
are going to get a 60-day free trial you
can't beat that ship station make ship
happen
you see my twitch right now it's the
dryness of the allergies do you see it
though yeah
no actually no you don't decide right
here i don't it's actively twitching
right now
can you zoom in on his eye pimp
do we see the twitch right it's
happening right now tag at hey babe
dm hey babe do you see his eye twitch
hey babe babypod at gmail.com i feel
like pulsing and twitching i'm telling
you it's dryness in the eyes and how
much coffee are you drinking are you
drinking any caffeine at all probably
zilchuroo
you drink zero cups of coffee i mean i
drink coffee but not every day like i
haven't had coffee in weeks i don't know
what maybe a cappuccino at dinner like a
week ago or something like that you
don't have to function with coffee every
day of your life no never ever pimp do
you
oh yeah addicted to coffee yeah i need
it all the time you've never in your
life got addicted to coffee no never
ever ever but isn't that bad because
once you do then you need it right i
mean that's what addiction is but i just
mean like i don't wanna i don't wanna i
probably one of the reasons i don't is
like i don't want to
first of all i can drink i'm a guy who
can drink a cup of coffee and go to bed
while i'm drinking it oh my god so i
don't know if it maybe because i just
i'd never felt those effects from it per
se maybe if i pay more attention or i
drink a lot of coffee i might feel it
but i never did but also like i don't
want to be that guy that needs one every
day otherwise i'm like no no before i
had my coffee i talked to you about the
little thing i saw about what that guy
did what 90 days no caffeine right did i
talk about that no i don't think already
no so the guy this guy michael polland
michael pollard or something he was on
uh the rogan show that's where i saw him
first and then
i followed him he didn't drink coffee
for 90 days 90 days zero coffee and he
said he he's a guy he's known for trying
every drug micro dosing every drug known
to man everything from cocaine mushrooms
fentanyl weed just everything micro dose
is it okay and then heroin isn't
fentanyl just a poison no fentanyl
fentanyl is a thing that's used in for
um
uh uh like you get put to sleep on it
like phenols it is uh didn't come out of
nowhere that's a medically right but
it's used by doctors yes but it's not a
drug that people trip on no no no no
it's a medicinal use okay people take it
outside of that and then die okay but
yeah so
so this guy
what he said was though after 90 days of
no coffee yeah he said it was the
hardest drug that he ever
uh took uh got off in his life he said
when he drank that first cup of coffee
after 90 days it hit his body harder
than any drug that he's abstained from
hit his body he said the thing is with
caffeine he goes there's a world pre and
post caffeine he goes pre-caffeine
everybody kind of walked around a little
buzz everyone had a little bit of
alcohol
in them even kids would drink like hard
cider because the water wasn't clean so
everybody had a buzz
he said and then caffeine comes into the
world around like the late 1600s and
then everybody
is on caffeine and coffee
kind of all the time always he said you
don't really know 1600s the late 1600s
when caffeine that's when coffee was
around yeah coffee so there was a guy
like i'm not beheading anyone until i
had my coffee yeah exactly yeah yeah
yeah well even the beheadings and the
hangs and how people you know like in
the ancient world like you'd be like how
could they do this to people most of
them were blackout drunk that's a real
thing even kings and queens blackout
drunk when they're beheading people oh
yeah because they're just that that's
what they did the same way they didn't
realize that they were drunk because
they didn't have a wasn't the science
errors yet wasn't there yet we don't
realize how over caffeinated we are that
like me i've had three cups of coffee
this morning whatever the baseline me is
isn't on this podcast right wow
caffeinated me so
so she said he said the people who never
got addicted to caffeine in that way are
the closest versions to who they
actually are well i am sluggish quite
often yeah that's what you're supposed
to be yeah a sluggish well we're all
supposed to be a little sluggish yeah
because caffeine what happened it really
came out big in the industrial
revolution when you needed to hyper
focus on a piece of machinery or
whatever you pressing all these levers
where in the mid mid medieval times you
could kind of be drunk because all
you're doing is like plowing a field
sure you're feeding it you can be a
drunk idiot but you can't be drunk
operating that's that's amazing i never
really thought of it that way yeah so
that sky so they were they were all
alcoholics you think oh
it was common for children to be
drinking hard cider at like nine so
everybody had a little bit of buzz
because the water wasn't safe to drink
if you drank the water you can get a you
know uh
kill you right but alcohol was cleaner
and safer it was boiled right because it
was right right it was uh fermented
fermented so so distilled yeah maybe not
still back then
so is there is there any
youtube videos of drunk children
does that happen
like that's good like i don't know
a drunk kid
eight-year-old boy served alcohol root
beer tji fighters no but alcoholic root
beer
wait what
like i don't know like have you ever
seen like a kid drawing a child's name's
addict like a kid got into the liquor
cabinet and he puts it on youtube and
the kids took edibles by accident
drunk nine-year-old scooter kid at skate
park oh god this might just be click
bait i mean i've seen it in real life
i've seen it like house parties gone
wrong a kid a kid a drunk kid but not a
child 11 year old
really an 11 year old like wow drunk
yeah no yeah well that's really great
yeah
it's creepy as [ __ ]
oh man i don't know
you ever see that movie good boys
yes is that with um uh team edward
or that's joyride
joyride is uh a thriller about a truck
driver that's murdering people
good boys is about sixth graders in this
summer
no
jacob trembley isn't it yeah jacob
tremblay he's he was in the movie um he
was in that movie uh like uh
he won like an academy award or
something
what's the movie won academy award for
it was he got kidnapped him and his
mother and they kept him in a garage oh
yeah yeah it's called like home or
something like that that movie was sick
with um with the girl who played uh miss
um
cap no not captain america what'd she
play yeah yeah who's that what's that
actress she's a big actress she's a huge
actress yeah what did she play captain
universe we're talking about mom right
now she's like what is she playing who's
the actress who played in the
room
yeah brie larson
brie larson
so that's jacob tremley as like a
younger kid right this movie was crazy
this movie was nuts because it could
really like happen it was crazy but in
the in the good boys yo you didn't watch
good boys it's one of the funniest
comedies in like the last 10 years dude
really it is so funny i'm gonna watch it
tonight so they're all in like fifth
grade or whatever and the kids like i
you won't one of the bullies is like you
won't come to dr drink a beer he's like
look what i gotta stole a beer so they
go into the woods and like the bully's
like testing the other kids and like
there's like the bully kids and then him
and his nice good boys so they cracked a
beer and he's like
i feel it already right like they're
passing one beer around and they're all
like sipping it and it's like whoa me
too and they pass it at him and he like
he's scared that's just a bit so he like
fakes simpson and he goes and he goes to
hand it to his his friend he goes
it's hot
[Laughter]
it's so so it's like not a kid it's like
it's like it's kids
it's more like rated r i think it's a
rated r uh comedy who directed it isn't
it seth rogens
uh this dude i know who directed it too
i tried to connect with this guy
uh i forget yeah he wrote it into good
boys dude it's so there's a lot of
funnies like this that i just haven't
seen
like i haven't seen pineapple express oh
that was good i haven't seen boys
eisenberg yeah that's the godfather he
you know he know what he did he was a
big office guy in the office i think he
was like an exec producer or like a like
a big writer on the office lee eisenberg
yeah that guy right there is he catholic
he it's you know i don't i don't know
could be i don't know it could be um
convert uh keith l williams
is a child actor though
keith oh yeah yeah yeah he's okay
the first three kids in the childhood
kids okay i met that kid there i think
too will forte was never in snl
did you think he was like part of the
cast of snl for years
do you think will forte was in snl for
years
i know he was no no no then then
somebody else you think was in snl and
they weren't
it's somebody else um
there's who's like will forte
bill hader no john krasinski no google
will who's like people think we'll this
guy was on snl and he wasn't you
definitely sound like my mom now google
p this guy everybody thinks this guy was
on snl but he wasn't uh
uh
people think this guy was on snl but he
wasn't no oh god no come on who
everybody it's like it's like one of
those things jim carrey no it's like one
of those things like in the mate like
it's a glitch in the matrix thing like
how you know oh the the the the the the
the thing to talk about embarrassed yeah
like bears staying bearish it's like
this like this guy was never on snl who
is it who's like he's like
no i know what you mean oh and he looks
like will forte it's not jason davis
because i know he's on snapchat okay
yeah i know he's looking like
google who looks like will forte it's
yeah who reminds you of will forte
it's a guy he's funny he's in a bunch of
movies too
who is mcgoober
will forte [ __ ]
mcgruber
yeah i know what you mean i feel like i
know what you mean it's a guy when
you're like he was in snl foreign a lot
so he's a big enough celebrity to have
hosted it a lot
why do we associate him with snl because
he had to have hospitals because he
looks like will forte like paul rudd no
who looks like will forte did you google
that already pimp i did yeah [ __ ]
i i'll literally kill myself what about
what about on the part don't do it don't
do it what about i oh put in i always
thought this guy was on snl
maybe that's how people talk am i gonna
have to take it up a bloom cafe
take it up with blue cafe
um
wait steve martin
no
god oh steve martin on snow everybody
he's the whole guy was on snl
damn it
hold on
hold on hold on benedict cumberbatch
holly barry
who
look who reminds you
reminds
reminds you who's you the internet
who is it isn't there an app that you go
oh oh oh is it martin short no he was
honest who who's the brother in in in uh
blades of glory who's the john
heater
the kid from napoleon dynamite no no no
adam scott no no adam scott's a good
guess though hold on hold on
no
that's sheamus
uh
will arnett
williams arnett was never on snl i know
that everyone knows that oh
that's who you really believe i thought
will arnett was will forte okay i don't
know i see it i get i get it they're
both name will you don't think when you
look at will or not you're like i know
who's on snl no i i well only because
i'm very familiar with will arnett so
maybe that's why i knew that for miller
are you
why how familiar are you can you say it
on camera we've been up downtown and
uptown wow
so you know we'll learn that personally
no i was going to say i want to send him
a voice and i'll be like i thought you
were going i'd love to have him on the
show man oh my god let's get willard
knight in a hologram on the show can you
remind me of that i'm going to see if he
can be on the show david cross was just
on the show speaking of
oh he's talking about practical jokes i
think you're talking about hey babe oh i
would love this david cross episode hey
babe would be amazing
yeah will arnett do you know he hosts a
show it's on hulu i guess it was on fox
maybe about like lego competitions who
does will arnett will arnett does yes
it's it's the lego masters yes dude i
watched two straight seasons of this
[ __ ] during the choir
it is it is blow your balls off amazing
what channels of two i watched on hulu
but
teams of two teams of two people that
are experts in lego have like
it's over days like they'll be like all
right this is the theme today go ahead
there's a room full of a billion legos
and they go you have 12 hours to build
this and they build it over 12 hours and
then they all judges judge theirs and
compete someone can you just put lego
masters and hit images on some of them
dude you can't believe
what they built you cannot believe it
it's it's it's it's unreal
it's stuff you like it's it's it
it's that's
these things that move there's like
literal robots it's insane look see that
thing that was a shark breaking through
it like look at that they made that out
of legos yes
yo y'all crazy like that look like look
at that like that's look at that i mean
it's just insane dude they are crazy
that's like did you see you see the new
um movie that's coming out um
uh that uh
who's
why am i blind guys
jordan peele yeah movie oh yeah the new
horror movie it's so funny it's like a
horror movie and it's like it's it's
it's it's like you can't miss that guy
well you can't miss it's like you know
it's like a predominantly like all black
cast and it's like it's like a it's like
a scary movie where it's like just like
shadows and it's like crazy movie i saw
coming traction sports like crazy movie
um you know like there's just like
sounds in the distance it's horrifying
and the name of the movie is nope
that's the name of the movie
yes
nope i saw the trailer i was like
hilarious
yes yes absolutely dying laugh i i was
at the movie theater seeing that movie
the northmen like actually went to
theaters and it was an audible laugh out
loud when one nope when the name of the
movie was
dude it's a little relevant do little
rell's in every movie i watch now he's
in every single movie lil rel shout out
a little rel get a little rel on the
show i would love to have a little real
on the show on the show i love it why
not
i don't do to get little in front of
your name
just tell people
i think if we start if you saw it right
now if you like look chris look if you
said call me little cell yeah literally
said call me a little song we'll call
you a little sound
and i think at first i'd be like oh wow
it's weird sal's kind of you know going
crazy or if i said call me a little
chris but then after a couple of weeks
i'd be little chris you'd be little cell
little pimp
we should have different personas when
we talk as little chris little sal a
little pimp
like maybe it's just like an alter ego
you know what the perfect persona for
little chris would be
jamaican oh
little chris in the house
you know i'm little chris and i said
what up sal how you doing
yeah look chris do me a favor we'll see
you again next week but why don't you
sign off
nepean hey babe
what was the first word you said
don't be a fake don't be a flake don't
run away from your feelings don't be
afraid don't be ashamed don't hesitate
to say hey babe hey babe hey babe